wie lange wir noch abstand halten müssen
diese frage steht seit tagen eben raum
wann können wir wieder den urlaub bis
ostern
die hoffnung darauf sind natürlich schon
weg aber auch die sommerferien sind ein
großes thema und genau darüber haben wir
heute gesprochen mit ministerpräsidentin
manuela schwesig aus mecklenburg
vorpommern die frage natürlich wann
können die deutschen endlich wieder
urlaub an der ostsee machen wann darf
man sich wieder frei bewegen wann darf
man wieder nach mecklenburg vorpommern
ich hoffe sehr dass wir bald wieder
jetzt empfangen können
wenn wir durch die schlimmste phase
durch sind das können sie mir glauben
wir sind gerne tourismusland nummer eins
und das ist gerade sehr hart für uns
auch emotional dass gäste nicht zu uns
kommen können und dass wir gäste sogar
nach hause schieben mussten aber es geht
um den schutz der gesundheit der
bevölkerung und der gäste vor allem die
grenze nach mecklenburg vorpommern
werden momentan stärker kontrolliert als
beispielsweise die grenzen zu unserem
nachbarland den niederlanden wie fühlen
sie sich damit dass es so eine strenge
kontrollen zu ihrem bundesland gibt
ich finde diese maßnahme richtig denn
wir haben wir zusammen entschieden dass
es in deutschland keine urlaubsreisen
mehr geben darf und deshalb muss es
natürlich irgendwie konnten hier werden
wir können es nur in unserem land und
wir können es nicht in ganz deutschland
machen und es ist deshalb wichtig weil
sonst zum beispiel toaster 800.000
besucher zu uns kommen
das ist die hälfte unserer einwohnerzahl
und wir können nicht für eine so große
zahl in zeiten wo der tourismus
runtergefahren ist keine infrastruktur
da ist und auch unser land nicht die
große gesundheitliche versorgung für so
viele leute hat dieses risiko in denen
das ding zum schutz aller welt vorkommen
ein riesiges tourismusland also gibt es
also bald dort viele gesunde hoteliers
die aber pleite sind
nein wir stürzen jetzt gerade nicht
trostlos branche mit zuschüssen der
grund hat ja nur einen wunsch an das
programm unternehmen bis 10 aber in dem
moment arbeitnehmer wir haben es auch
stopp bis 100 arbeitnehmer
lima und unterstützen unsere branche
unsere unternehmen wirtschaftliche
folgen in der korona krise aber
natürlich auch viele private
einschränkungen vor allem jetzt zu
ostern keinen besuch mehr bei der
familie möglich wie geht ihre familie
damit um das ist ganz strengen gehabt
und uns genau wie vielen anderen
für uns ist groß das ist absolute
verliert das in der regel fanden wir ein
paar tage zum urlaub an der ostseeküste
das findet nicht statt
und dann haben wir zu meinen eltern nach
frankenburg also zur oma und opa meiner
kinder auch das findet dieses jahr nicht
statt was mich auch persönlich als
tochter sehr schwer
meine eltern nicht zu sehen weil ich sie
sowieso schon selten sehe und die eigene
oma also meine schwiegermutter die in
der gleichen straße wohnt nur ein paar
häuser weiter dann kann es zurzeit ihre
enkel nicht sehen weil sie eben alles
vor risikogruppe gehören so wie ich
persönlich ja auch und deswegen erlebt
meine familie gewann auch sehr hart die
einschnitte die viele anhin deswegen
verstehe ich auch den schmerz und den
wunsch dass endlich alles vorbei ist
aber deswegen trage ich auch die
verantwortung auch die gesundheit gerade
auch der älteren zuschauer
das ist für niemanden einfach aber vor
allem kinder können damit schwer umgehen
wie sieht das bei ihnen in der familie
aus die wind hin- und hergerissen die
finden das total hoch dass sie gerade
oma und opa nicht sehen können und wir
versuchen jedem zu staaten viel zu
telefonieren
auf der anderen seite genießen sie es
dass wir jetzt immer am samstagabend
kino alle machen wir schrieben uns mit
den pinselohren laden uns einen schönen
kinofilmen runter möglichst was lustiges
sind das gerade auf dem sofa und die
familienzeit jetzt mehr als sonst
genießen sie auch sie haben gerade
selber wenn sie gehören auch zur
risikogruppe was genau bedeutet das für
ihren corona alltag
ich habe einmal mehr irgendwelche
gemacht dass ich eine brustkrebs in köln
bin und habe in diesem halben jahr schon
sehr stark schutzmaßnahmen eingehalten
also hände desinfizieren regelmäßig
hände waschen nicht mehr groß auch
kontakte die ich hab das liebevoll in
diesem beruf am 10
roth genannt was jetzt für viele gilt
ich bin sehr froh dass ich viel von
dieser die hinter mir habe und auch
schon mein immunsystem fitter ist aber
natürlich gilt auch für mich dass ein
restrisiko bleibt allerdings ist für
mich klar dass da die präsidentin der
kapitän geht von bord